[Music]
reading and math scores have long been
the primary measure of American
schooling but how much do rising test
scores actually tell us about schools a
lot less than we'd like
in spring 2018 for instance researchers
noted teacher impacts on test scores are
almost entirely uncorrelated with
teacher impacts on student classroom
behavior attendance truancy and grades
why might that be
well when test scores go up it can mean
that students are learning more but it
can also mean that schools are spending
a lot of time on test preparation
shifting attention from other subjects
for reading and math or gaming the
statistics if a pediatrician started
seeing an impressive number of patients
because she stopped doing thorough
examinations we probably would not
celebrate her performance that's because
it matters how she improves her SATs in
the same way it matters how schools
raise their test scores higher scores
may mean that schools are getting better
or that they're just pretending to do so
how much do you think test scores matter
let us know in your comments also let us
know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI